whatever something leads and it is my
pleasure to bring Loaf you Joe and Jane
Holly my Samuel hi welcome to the show
these guys are amazing and I'm delighted
that they've come down to share their
story and to talk to you a little bit
about some of their strategies which are
very different to the stuff that I use
you talked about so why don't we just
kick off Joe tell us about what it is
that you must do and a little bit of
background about yourselves okay the
background where we started in our
previous lives we used to be
hairdressers you look like a hairdresser
and the first property we worked out of
we actually converted into four
apartments above someone and that got
was in she was strategy which is titled
letting to find larger properties where
we can add value and we convert hold on
hold on this is correct so you were
hairdressers and come again what
happened what happened to us we had a
flap of our first hairdressing salon
yeah first home but the Sun right that
kind of time moves on and we went ahead
and we bought our first house yeah and
we moved out but we were an in property
so it just stayed empty and we kind of
used it for staff room in a storeroom
yeah
it stayed for years I stayed empty this
is a book yeah yeah and it's just like
an empty bit that you own yeah yeah what
happened well one day we were watching
something I've been on the television
and Joe said should we convert this into
flats and we knew no difference so we
said well yeah maybe this these two
rooms are going to and flat
perhaps another flat there and then
another one there and it was a great two
listed building in a conservation area
but you know different so we stuck the
plans in and shooter like it was the
hardest planning application
we ever go through we were learning we
were learning we were learning yeah but
you know what it parts so hold on you
bought the hairdressers place yeah moans
did you buy it for
well we actually paid well we bought the
commercial lease in 1980 yeah we paid
one hundred and twenty five thousand for
the actual freehold in 88 this is we're
gonna like a long time yes developing
this planning didn't start until the
late nineties so then the late nineties
when you so you did spurt how many flats
did you put it in located four flats
like too bad and it meant a two-bit
apartment yeah for where and then did
you sell them or keep them man what we
did then
mercy and then we let them out we still
own the property so we let them out yeah
and we watch the rent coming in we still
carried on running all our guests
themselves could be a six at the time
yeah but kind of whenever there was a
bank holiday or something like that used
to cost us fifteen hundred pounds and
hairdressers if you need that kind of
thought stuff but we kind of watch the
rent coming in and we thought we like
this this sounds good
yeah so we just exploded it from there
and presumably the money that you're
making are for apartments you know that
was a reasonable amount of cash flow and
we should thinking about at this point
hmm the money that we're making off the
property that's actually easier money
the money what I mean okay well in fact
I've sponsored it more because we
actually sold the hairdressing salons to
other hairdressers and we still owe the
freehold
but on a commercial lease so we actually
found that the guaranteed income that
the tenants were paying yes some weeks
actually exceeded the kind of profit
moment were there you know it always
stress and the worry in the hassle of
running natural salon and there's 60
hairstylist at one time
believe me that can be stress and yeah
believe yeah again I'm so so then open
well then what happened was my mother
watched what we were doing and she used
to this is sorry this is a start for
cooking yeah yeah we realized because
like Jane said with the Sun when we saw
the businesses we certainly realized we
were earning more through the vent from
the commercial unit
and the for pot is above than working 60
hours a week behind the chair yeah so we
fought well we like this it's the my mom
watch this yeah and she used to get the
coach the train from Bristol to
weston-super-mare to go ballroom dancing
every week yeah and she said genius I'd
love a little flower of my own how can
we do this so I could stay down there
for a few nights so we said well hang on
what about if we were to buy a big
property and maybe make a flat for you
one part of it but then the other flats
could pay for it okay
actually said I'd like that and so it's
exactly what we did we got murmur at
Seaside flat with two flats above and
then we later developed two parts behind
which meant that we had mums flat
totally for free and it meant that the
mortgage on mums flat was being paid for
by the income from the properties are
surrounded it that's amazing well it was
amazing and Sophie and this is long
before title splitting kind of was like
a strategy you know kind of banded about
there wasn't any property education even
in there exactly yeah and we just
discovered this by accident a broker
friend of ours so behind a minute how
about if we would create a separate
lease on each of those flats and take
our separate buy to let mortgage because
of course they only came out in the mid
90s yeah I have been I wrong how about
is that if we do a separate buy to let
mortgage we could raise the value and
then we've got all the money out so
you'll actually even put money in your
pocket still in the property I have mum
strapped for free I thought this is
sounded even more exciting yeah so we
felt it works once yeah let's go it
lives more times and so we carried on
doing all the way round crystal and
Western Superman you just started buying
up the flat splits in the middle you
just start of buying anything anything
as joe says that it don't move that's
our motto
doesn't move for convergence so so tell
me tell me where you're at today then so
is this something that you're still
doing today
so very much very much so we love to buy
commercial buildings they're not always
sometimes by residential
and we don't always turn things
residential craft and we keep them
commercial because we remember the
income from our commercial Harrison sons
so we quite like commercial tenants
that's another story so we do that quite
a lot yeah so but now we've got public
portfolio lots and lots of tenants and
we don't want anymore so for the last
couple of years what we've been really
focusing on is converting bigger
properties into apartments or houses or
commercial units and then actually
selling them on and so on that's cool
that's cool and I think it's amazing how
many different ways they're all that you
can make money in property oh so many so
minutes I make an art just one yeah
there's so many different strategies and
people are you know buying and selling
title splitting renting yeah I mean on
average so for instance tell me what
would a typical what you didn't know
make you buying a property and you split
it up and in selling the flats on or
whatever how much profit would you get
well Prince does the latest project that
were just about to start upon that
everyone always thinks it has to be an
office into flats and that's kind of not
the case at all
so what we're doing is taken X cotton
mill yeah I will not create that we're
not splitting it horizontally at all
we're splitting it vertically because
there's too many it's too many flats in
the area still not broken it amount so
we're actually creating time houses so
this particular project we're working on
now will purchase for three to seven the
gdv of e 1.6 just over and the profits
should have a four in front of it so
it's some really exciting strategy but
we're creating what the market demands
not what we are structured with us is
well in a way were the good guys because
lot man would get bad press people right
there saying all these landlords are
taken away from first-time buyers
how can people on the point without in
which it's completely unfounded but we
would take properties what people don't
want ugly
properties abandoned properties and to
you underused and we convert them into
apartments or into townhouses so we
actually bring it back to life
properties what Ben
empty for years yeah yeah watch with a
certain amount of amusement everybody do
any no serviced accommodations kind of
lightly sexy strategy yeah and we watch
everybody having trouble with you know
freeholder and so on yeah we think how
were the freeholders we now have trouble
that if we want to do serviced
accommodation with a dictate workers oh
yeah yeah yeah whenever we retain any
property we retain the freehold that's
nice cause you know so give me an
example then Joe best property table
that you've done best property do there
was one of our early one which we
converted this into this is when we were
hairdressing we work for strategy what
you would find in we move from a rented
premises into our own premises the
hairdressing salon and we converted
above into two apartments or two-bedroom
than one bedroom beautiful listed
building low beams how much this is
going back a few years ago back maybe
twenty year but it's all relevant for
white port for then today in profit so
how much you think people's property for
so before you do anything to it yeah it
was a opticians you know moved out into
Newark bigger premises yeah sure twenty
years ago seventy five thousand pounds
never guess yes twenty thousand pounds
half so boarding ten thousand pounds and
then you sold it for how much hundred
ninety one hundred and ninety thousand
that is ridiculous and how long the
period was that over this is a couple of
years but the point is is that this
growth wasn't due to capital growth in
the area
yeah I also earned quite extensive
rental profits in the two years at a
ground yeah you rented out for a couple
years made good
income from the rent yeah and then
cheese that sort of for 190 yes
that's we did we had the build cost yeah
but still but is a big fact it's great
because we call that one of our best
deals because we had we have no money no
financing and little holding costs
because we've not sharing the building
what we were actually doing the work as
well
yeah so it's a truly creative deal that
earned profit had nothing really yeah
yeah so so that's what happens at its
best when you do it really well that's
what happens when when you have to be
creative yeah I think the problem is I
think as if things got too good there
are 2006 2007 year of course we just
scratched times in that kind of stuff
I think then things kind of got too easy
and because of that then you maybe think
you don't have to be as creative you
know you could you can just go and do
things anyway yeah and we look back to
some of our earlier times and we think
we were really creative really quick
give me an example of a property deal
that you've recently done maybe the last
year or two there's been a nice healthy
[Music]
just finishing now yeah yeah it was a
care home yeah
ex care home betrayed in 30 years and
closed on the Planning Commission is our
first non listed building since 2010 and
we got planning permission to convert
into six apartments which we did right
and all that through a really smoothly
planning or went through smoothly with
the build and so on we actually worked
with CGI so sold off plan yeah after the
reservations so it was all sold before
the build was completed then at the
bottom of the garden was a garage which
I got planning permission to convert
that into a coach house so we're totally
maximizing the plot here you know
throughout the song it sounds exciting I
wanna know the figures so for all the
figures you haven't say see guys and
computer-generated images we've never
worked for before we've seen other
builders using them yeah and we thought
we'll try one on this bill
and like Jean said we convert into six
departments Alma did he see guys so they
would come in the people doing would
come in they would measure all of them
above mine now this room could be dozen
builders in here no windows in no doors
here at they do all the measurements and
then they do a complete
computer-generated image of how it's
gonna look at the finish okay oh yeah
and that's fantastic and the or sold off
plan it never seemed appropriate to us
before because do list of buildings kind
of always feel you have to stage the
property and make the property that are
people cuz or fill the history of the
building yeah and so on but we think
this came over just as well in the CGI's
and the amount of holding cost like that
don't you cinematic yes so that you'll
be doing again will be doing that a lot
more in compute you know in conjunction
with conversions as opposed to new build
yeah so this dealer that he did what was
the cost of buying the we've we bought
it for $5.99 so that wasn't and that
wasn't below market valuation six
thousand pounds
yes market value yeah but then you can
added value so how much is the
conversion gonna be in such a including
all the builders overseeing costs and
the building cost can't have come out
about 320 are going to another coach
hikes to build as well and the GDP now
this is where it gets interesting
because the GDP if we if we go ahead and
do the whole lot is in a reach of about
one point for that kind of reach yeah
however we've now got planning
permission for the coach-house
but before we actually start doing the
build just go through a period now of a
couple of weeks but we're trying to sell
it so it just don't to somebody else to
develop so we're taking a planning
uplift game and particularly benefit
there is to sell to possibly a self
builder because then they're not liable
for the council infrastructure that
either sale so how much profit then once
you've done all the projects you bought
it for 600 you spent 320 on the builders
do they have a few other things to build
and do it off in an 1800 and they're
like really yeah
twelve months we put what we purchased
in January last year so including full
plan and including all the bills the
reservations were taken in November well
I mean if you could just do one of those
a year mmm this is all the figure what
yeah you know that keeps us happy yeah
I'm not into doing these big you know
kind of hundred flat compartments and
you know in that kind of yeah because we
think we would rather have two smaller
projects hedging our bets at different
areas of times on because you see
remember that we said we bought our
first commercial freehold in 1988 yeah
well we've so we really well remember
the 88 to 2000 88 to 91 says me credit
crunch yeah not to mention the latest
well the 2007 and so we've always got
very much an eye on safety and back yes
I mean that sounds wonderful you know
buying a house buying a property for 10
grand and then selling it for 190 making
two three hundred thousand pounds per
deal doing a couple of those a year you
can see what other strategies very
attractive yes and also there's no no
tenants no need for tenants and it's fun
I mean people me included just enjoy a
project yeah you know it's fun and
making hundreds of thousands of pounds
it's also kind of fun so give me give me
give me the hard cold truth reality of
some of the hardships and some of the
problems that come along with doing
these kinds of deals okay planners
planners plumbers you know kind of
everybody is supposed to follow national
guidelines yeah I'm set some you know
local plans young set policies that
doesn't take into account the human
factor okay it doesn't take into account
perhaps the whim of a conservation
officer or the whim of a planning
officer yeah or introducing a policy
path through the building so the
coach-house certainly needed 50 square
meters of amenity space we have to
concede some of the living room for that
now do we agree with that no we don't
yeah but you know
you couldn't do it yeah dealing with
getting planning permission could be is
never it's never a guarantee never
guarantee you do all the due diligence
at what point do you get guidance about
Planning Commission is it is it like
right at the beginning or always we
always get guidance why the baby get out
we would get our consultant we
specialize in listed buildings a lot of
people run away from listed building
because you need to get planning forget
you that for the 20 years we've been
doing this we haven't touched would you
have had a conversion planning
application fell okay but we make sure
we get 95% certainty that what we're
looking at we can convert so our
planning people will bring up the
council torture Joe holding no hoozy but
they talked to John Phillips because
he's a planning for soldiers so yeah so
John asked him I've got some clients
were looking at ABC this is what I'd
like to do what your views on it yeah
sure so if they say quite happy about
this then we'll move it forward a bit
more
then what would often try and do we will
always manage get it is we've put in the
office so get you planning yeah so we
will buy this building if we will get
the plan got it really good so everybody
needs a john phillips in their life do
you know a policy as well how do you get
a john phillips in your life
recommendation and what would use the
job description be to a planning
consultant yeah so really good really
good lesson there then yeah if you're
gonna be doing this you need to know how
much do you guys know or have to know
about plans and you have to be really
clean up as well
a pretty good idea yeah obviously you
can't bring the guy can get into in
every project you see should only do a
heck of a lot due diligence online
yeah and that kind of stuff if you
filter out all the basic stuff
generally the properties that we go to
view ninety-five percent of the time we
will actually offer on because really
the view in more or less just confirms
what we have suspected so when you said
that the biggest problem in the business
is planning is that it's a limit how
it's one of the biggest is that is that
the council kind of like moving
goalposts a little bit stuff it could be
and also I'm just the interpretation
yeah
can that be an absolute deal breaker
could it be that you've said I'll boil
subjective planning you've got the
planning approved then you're in the
middle of getting all builders to do
stuff the campus will go hey I don't say
that and there's a slot missing
temptation could it be that it's good
out of it once they given you planning
your you would care but you have to
stick to the plan with your strategy
could you really end up in the nest
could you end up you know it going about
do due diligence and then being
completely screwed over what scares me I
think is when I see somebody have an
unconditional offer accepted where
they've not done sufficient due
diligence yeah and they haven't got
confirmation from at least two different
planning officers or conservation
officers director the consultant
preferably in writing maybe not been
through a pre-op or something like that
and so then they've gone ahead and
they've put good money down for it
yeah I've also not checked the demand of
their project needs at the end so
sometimes they can even go ahead and
force through the planning to get
something you know in that building
yeah and they discover at the end of it
there's no demand for it nobody wants it
yeah Matt you know then you're in you
you you end up with a project that isn't
profitable because it doesn't have the
right configuration that's not news we
do has six months or 12 months of your
life yeah not to make any money
you are bridging and development finance
possibly as well could be catastrophic
and I know when people don't follow
what mission yeah you have a 2000 flat
and your meeting two three-bedroom flat
yeah I mean to get all signed off yeah
are there any other big major problems
or potential challenges to doing this
sort of you know I think the majority of
the challenges don't come from people
like us yes or within the industry it's
kind of changes from outside government
changes I forced it upon us yeah you
know for instance you know the strategy
of exchange contracts going to your
development complete on the development
reaiiy that's the next day you know the
kind of mortgages stress kind of thing
yeah people it worked you know it were
tops are you find of course that was
with jewel just you know straight away
like yeah yeah that's of course all the
bites let lending them all came down
which meant that people didn't have
access for the projects that they were
perhaps working on yeah a lot of the
bigger developers had projects pulled
from under them thankfully we only
worked on smaller projects which we were
able to you know sort of get out of and
still carry on and run our portfolio to
us all the develop the finance dried up
as well oh yeah I know there's been
major changes and effective not just you
guys but also yeah the whole property
industry so what would you say to
somebody that wanted to have a go at
doing a project even as a small product
if it was just like buying a big house
and converting it into two or three
flats that's exactly where we advise
people to start right do a self is small
don't start doing one of these office
250 flats yeah yeah start with something
that can go two three four flats
something like that that's alright yeah
or maybe a shop with two flats per birth
you can even do inter prior approval
yeah it's a small office but you can get
prior approval to do a couple of flats
in well but make sure that you know
there's a good demand for whatever your
proposed
to build make sure the figures really
really sucked up yeah but checked
everything our most important of all
back up and then another back up so we
say even if you're planning or selling
that's fine but what if the market turns
right what if something really
unpredictable happens in a world market
will you be able to rent that property
in the same time will you be able to
carry on and renting the property so you
don't you never maneuver yourself we
have to sell it down today yeah then and
never back up to back that up if I could
just out there mmm
a lot of people work a lot see ya and I
always say do your due diligence put you
offer in is if we don't put office in
you're not going to get anything
accepted yeah then you can do more to
diligence
once it gets accepted yeah don't wait
for it to be perfect because if you wait
for your website to be perfect perfect
yeah it's a fine line isn't it between
you know not wanting to plan plan plan
plan plan it you never do yeah the same
time not pushing ahead because there's
nothing more scary than a motivation
idiot yes just doing it doesn't have a
clue what they do is you don't wanna
lose credibility by you know thrown off
as in so let's say swords watching this
video and they're like really inspired
that they love the idea of doing
projects and title split' scene they
heard the story about you guys when you
have no idea what you do yeah so I
started no money no experience no skill
nope no network so let's say someone's
watching this video they go right I want
to I want to find a big old house where
I can see the house I can see it be big
enough to be maybe three flats I can I
can see that three flats would sell for
this much this looks really exciting the
view it great they need to know about
the planning they've no clue about
whether then be able to split it up do
they after then find a planning
consultant because first off is the
Queen City
you don't need parking crystal Ron just
up the road about 10 miles Gloucester
Road North South Gloucestershire yeah
do you need time okay yeah so wins and
you know works oh yeah yeah that makes
sense so it's exciting it's a good
strategy you need to take action but you
do need a little bit of support and you
need to know claw what you do anything
about you diligence
yeah you did double-checking how many
deals how many deals are around like are
there loads of potential deals where are
there are deals in fact yeah it's
actually no mean we do mentoring alone
when one of our mentees one day said oh
I can't find any deals there's no deals
about anywhere and so when we put the
phone down I just went online just is
truly for five minutes
yeah and this project I thought wow it's
like deal today
yeah so did the figures did a bit of due
diligence a few phone calls
yeah went along to do the view it yeah
this is a deal that's so good yeah and
this is our time houses with big big
profit and you know what to this day I
don't understand why nobody else phoned
us up to say what do you think of this
do you think this is a good project with
them if I get you that as well though we
go to monthly mastermind meetings and we
were talking along last one meeting and
somebody said oh it's not really until
20 and when we found it popped you right
up is it still on the market
yes it's on the market so they've gone
that about you today to do a viewing
yeah I may not come to it that may not
come to it yeah but it's dry yes
yeah now do you have yeah keep looking
like that be consistent yeah be
consistent don't you know people
sometimes look for one week two weeks
and they think oh there's nothing out
there yeah I think you just keep on
being consistent keep on speaking to the
ages keep on speaking you know to
everybody you meet do you know actually
our builders have bought us four
properties in the past that's great but
they know that there's something in it
for them
of course incentivize people make it
worth people's while to help you cool
course so what are your plans for the
future and what are you guys planning on
doing
the next or 12 months or so doing what
we do you love what we do we love we
would kind of find the creative James's
dog creature I love finding the deals
negotiating for the deals what's the
deal was get accepted I have got the
interest and I don't care what curtains
so I love going out finding deals yeah
so yes there will be will be during the
time houses build we're selling couple
of new build planning permissions off
plan at the moment right and expanding
hugely more into the education because I
love that I love that you guys are doing
deals making hundreds of thousands of
pounds do really well but then you're
still taking time to help Italy for me
there's a lot of controversy isn't there
out there about kind of planners people
will do in education in property and the
only other conversation with somebody
and online yesterday and I think what
people thought to realize is that people
watching what we were doing and I made a
phone up so can you can you help me yeah
sure can we come in look at the deal
yeah of course
I think it was when it got a stage when
Joe was spent in two to three hours
every night through props
four nights a week and we were spending
three days a week shown people around or
I'm not having time for anything that
would yeah hang on a minute you know we
you know we aren't with the best will in
the world and we love love helping
people but we're really not a charity
example so that's kind of how the
property grew up and then we can ask the
same questions over and over again and
we think just come one day course
three-day course exam program right now
they're doing met you bring up together
to me and you'll help now with yeah and
blow yourself I just think that if
you've got the information and and you
know that you can change life by
teaching it not to teach it would be a
sick we spent twenty years making quite
a few errors along those years
yes I don't believe them you know we've
had some joint ventures which have gone
very badly wrong
yeah which we've learned a huge amount
from we've discovered projects where
maybe we didn't have sufficient back up
and that's cost us there maybe some of
the planning hasn't got exactly you know
we haven't got the exact configuration
so we've got always learning experiences
over 20 years I'll kind of somebody
who's just planning on coming into the
industry yeah sure you can go out there
make all the same mistakes again but
kind of wiry in that meal with either
the will we don't make the mistakes we
say to make sense just do that because
you make sense now we live on all I've
got certain skills you've got certain
knowledge skills we share so it up
brilliant well guys thanks for coming
down if it knows watch it would like to
touch and you've got a website or
something yeah sure is when property
buyers co uk win-win property buyers
good okay check these guys out there
absolutely amazing and hope you found
that beneficial thank you thanks Annie
of course you know
[Music]